all right
so today we're going to talk about
experiments in uh
consumer online products a b tests and
other similar things
uh before we begin uh just uh so that i
understand uh who is in the room uh
so that side of the room excluding those
guys uh show of hands who has analyzed a
b tests
okay who know what a b test is
okay great so that side of the room uh
who had the lunch today
no one had lunch today okay so i know
that response rate is about 30 percent
so probably more people in this group
actually did analyze a b test
at least i would hope that's the case so
before we begin
product madness what we do
it's very quick quick video
okay you got the point
we make social casino games they're not
gambling
so it's virtual money so you pay real
money to buy virtual currency and then
you gamble virtual currency and if you
win uh 10 million or billion you're not
able to take any money back it's just
virtual currency it just stays there
people still love that stuff and they
still pay money for that
um
so uh the goal of this tutorial and i
really want this to be a tutorial i
would like uh some of you who is
actually interested in the topic to take
away python notebooks that i prepared
and being able to apply uh some of this
learnings the main goal of this tutorial
is that i think data scientists
should not be using those simple a b
testing calculators not because they're
wrong absolutely fine
in some cases but because we're data
scientists and we really should be meant
to use python or r or some of those
advanced tools
you can still use them but just don't
show anyone that you're actually using
them and pretend that you're using bison
uh so about myself really quickly i'm
from ukraine from kiev
i have a degree in a probability series
from kiev university i've done a lot of
visual effects uh working in a big
blockbuster movies uh then i ate an mba
i was a product manager at king the guys
behind the candy crush saga and now i'm
heading a data science in the product
madness
there are different types of online
experiments which
companies in
our industry are doing there are
classical a b tests where parts of the
group are exposed to one variant of the
game and part of the group is exposed to
different
we also have some experiments that are
just ongoing for instance in marketing
activities you want to be able to test
the effectiveness of a specific marking
activity uh and
you keep your control group
running for a longer time so there is no
actual like end date for an experiment
why do we actually need to do
experiments
and ab tests in particular
obviously the main reason is to learn
the market preference
and also to actually
have a hard data to argue with
hippos and hippos is a highest
paid person opinion and sometimes those
guys win opinion and if you have hard
data it's actually much easier to
to talk to them
why do we need actually stats so in lots
of cases you can just look at the
outcome of your experiment and i'll be
showing some examples later on
um
you can just see that one group is
clearly outperforming the other group
but in a lot of cases the question is is
this uh do we just observe a randomness
here or is
the benefit or is one group definitely
outperforming the other group
so
all my examples will be based on this
fake game it's not real game it's almost
a real game
so it's match 3 similar to candy crush
for instance
and we will gonna talk about the story
of this fake game
so uh imagine that uh your team or uh
you're a data scientist embedded in this
product team and uh the developer team
has been working on this game for six or
eight months finally it's your launch
day he launched the game and now the
product manager is just
looking at the early performance of this
game
and
for some reason
maybe it's vice president of marketing
decided that the loading time for
initial loading screen should be below 3
seconds
that's apparently the performance of
one of their other
well performing game and so the first
goal if the game is performing well is
that the splash screen initially should
not take then three seconds
some early testing suggested that
the game loading is fine
but now product manager is looking at
this fake dashboard
and for last hour
average loading time actually exceeded
that magical three seconds so now he's
panicking he's just running to you as a
data scientist and ask you to figure out
should he actually even worry about it
is it statistically significant
does it mean that
the servers are not responding should we
take any actions or should we just
continue as normal
that's where stats comes in
there are different types of statistical
testing
however
there's only a few very
generic and widely statistical testing
that any any uh respectable data
scientist needs to know
uh in order to figure out which
statistical test to use first you
ask yourself whether you try to make an
inference based on one sample so in our
case we have
uh loading time for last hour and if we
want to figure out whether
it's uh
came from a population
where the average loading time is less
than three seconds or more than three
seconds or put in a different way in the
long run do we expect that the average
loading time will be below three seconds
or above three seconds
so uh we have one sample and we want to
calculate is to calculate the average
or mean
so we're going to use
that particular test
i will go in a little bit detail why
we're using t-test or not a z-test
however
for practical purposes it doesn't really
matter too much so use t-test if you
have large sample size it will be the
results will be the same as your test
so um how to use it in python there are
some math formulas that i don't want to
bother you with you can go back to slice
later on they will be published online
um
overall all statistical tests
and t-tests
the way it works is that is through a
data so these are individual observed
loading times for all the people who
visited your game in last hour
the t-test will give you a magical
t-value
you put this t-value in the
t-distribution and what you get is a
p-value and p-value is the probability
of observing data as extreme as that in
our case it was 3.5 seconds whatever
under the hypothesis that a long-running
average loading time is below 3 seconds
easy enough to code in python
of course you don't need to code it and
bison yourself
uh because most of those things already
implemented
and the takeaway uh for you from these
slides is
all the buy data is built on top of
numpy race as most of you know
there is a sci-fi stats it's a core
stats library
that implements quite a lot of tests
and at some point developers decided to
create stats model that starts where
they
implemented more specific models that
they thought are not fit for core
library
that's for classical statistics and then
there is a lot of
excitement currently about bayesian
statistics and
markov chain monte carlo models that you
can also use for statistical inference
and there are some libraries for that
too
so uh that's how you implement
the t-test
in
python you basically
say stats t-test one sample because we
are dealing with one sample and this is
array of loading times so all this data
is fake data so you can make photos of
my slides doesn't matter
and we get as an output of p value of
0.086
which basically means that there is
eight percent chance that the data that
we saw it could be
observed due to randomness and the long
running rate might be below 3 seconds
the same thing can be also we can use
z-test the point is
the p-value is very very close and
what it means is that you have large
enough sample size for t distribution to
be converging to z distribution t
statistics is the same as these
statistics just applied to different
distribution
well they never kind of really cross
they will converge when you have
a number of samples reaching infinity
however for practical purposes well
actually you can see that here
difference is not really that big
um so in my fake data i had 16 stalls
per hour
okay uh because uh you're lazy data
scientist and you don't want to
calculate this test
again every hour when your average time
is exceeding this magical three percent
threshold it's easy enough to put a
confidence interval on top of it and
give your product manager dashboard
and there is some python code for it
that you can review later and basically
you can create a dashboard that will
look like that and in the long run
you can see that yeah there was a few
spikes where loading time did exceed
that magical threshold however on
average it's fine
so moving back to
day number two
retention
retention is a percentage of users who
return to your
that's not good
okay
we return to your website
on a second day in this case we're
talking about day one retention
so we had
448 installs on the first day against
fake data it's i made it up and uh in my
fake data
123 users came back on a second day and
this vp of marketing said that
i will give you a media buying budget so
basically a budget to acquire users
to
do advertising on facebook and other
channels only if your day one retention
will hit at least 30 percent and now
product manager is actually worrying
that retention rate is only 27
so again he's coming to you and said can
i actually expect that it will kind of
stabilize what's what's the chance that
in the long run i will actually observe
retention rate of at least 30 percent
it's quite similar to a previous problem
however in this case we're dealing with
a proportion proportion of users who
decided to return on the next day and
the mass for that test is a little bit
different but not too much different
there is
actually a simpler formula
that i don't want to bother you with all
this is available in notebooks for
future reference
easy enough to implement in python and
there is a
z-test in this case in stats modules so
that's an example where this particular
test uh developers decided that it's not
fit for core
work side by stats package
and uh
what we're testing is a probability that
a long run retention rate will be 30
percent considering that everything else
will stay the same the p value for this
fake data is 11 which means that
there is actually a chance that things
will improve over time and we just were
unlike in the first day
and you can put the confidence interval
on top of uh that observation
and the conference 95 confidence
interval for that is that we can expect
that the long-running retention rate
will be somewhere between 23 which is
not that great and 31.
31
so product manager decided that actually
he needs to work on
retention and one way to retain users is
to uh implement is to
make as many users connect with facebook
on their mobile devices as possible
most games provide a connect to
facebook's functionality and our
fruitcrush epic game should not be an
exception
and what we want to see is where at
which point in the game when you want to
implement
this magical
dialogue that will prompt users to
connect to facebook
the hypothesis is that
more users will connect to facebook
after they finish level one so let's
give them level one to play uh let's
engage them a little bit and once they
complete this level then we'll show them
a dialogue to connect to facebook maybe
they will be more likely to actually
share their facebook credentials with us
and our default uh user
group will see a pop-up dialogue
straight after they load the game for
the first time
so i want to test which experiment will
lead to higher conversion rate
so in this made-up data
i imagine that we had around 2500
installs
and
more than a thousand people connected
here
and in the second group the group is
actually a little bit smaller because
there are some people who did not even
who did not finish level one who dropped
before finishing level one however out
of those people who did finish level one
we had uh half of them fifty percent
actually connect to facebook so we see
that in this fake data uh
we have more users connecting to
facebook after they completed level one
and now the question is is this
difference statistically significant
should we actually make a conclusion
based on that or should we
keep the test running for longer or
should we actually make another test or
maybe it doesn't matter at all
so in that case uh because we're
comparing two different samples
we're using that part of our tree and we
are
using a z-test for to calculate a
difference in two proportions
that's a mess for you if you're curious
and easy enough to implement in python
or to use a statsmodel.stats
one
kind of maybe not so so pleasant uh
thing about this particular
implementation that you actually need to
create a numpy array
to an umpire race uh
so you can uh apply this test
oh no actually it's
uh we can also calculate the confidence
interval for this particular test uh
and
to calculate the uplift that
our second flow uh generated and when we
calculated confidence interval it seemed
that the second flow uh is better but by
at least three percent or maybe as high
as nine percent
however uh the tricky bit about
a b testing and conclusions that
um you need to be very critical about
what you're actually analyzing so while
uh while our second flow actually did
generate a higher uplift
it seems that
it also we lost more users in a second
flow
this is a fake data so i just kind of
made it up it might it's not based on
any actually uh
real experiments that we've done in this
particular flow the point is that
if we do observe a high retention rate
in the first flow even so we connected
less users maybe actually the first flow
is still better so
conceptually it's can be hard to find
one right metric to analyze
the one right metric to actually analyze
and conclude your experiments is based
on a long long run
long-term lifetime value of your users
however calculating that and putting
confidence interval on top of that can
be very tricky in practice so in
practice we try to find uh metrics that
gives a good proxy an operational proxy
for uh our a b tests and if you can
analyze if you can
stick to analyzing proportions uh that's
much easier to conclude in line
experiments
so a few words about bayesian stats uh
there is an open source book uh written
in python notebooks
um bayesian methods for hackers and uh
in the second chapter of uh this book
the example is given uh this mcmc
algorithm is used to analyze an a b test
where they're testing proportions
uh
for this very very simple case there is
very little point of actually using uh
this hammer it's an overkill uh
and
the posterior distribution that mcmc
generates is actually
in this super simple case it's exactly
the same as what frequencies methods
gives you conceptually they are very
different things but the point is that
don't use mcmc to calculate the
difference in two binomial distributions
uh the first
a revenue-based a b test that's where
things get much more tricky
what we want to
analyze in this game and again the story
that i made up for that is uh
the pricing point for
extra life in our game uh the default
one was 9 199 and vp of marketing is
saying
that uh our conversion rate which means
percentage of users who are willing to
pay in our free game is very low
compared to competition
so what we should focus on is to
improve uh percentage of people who are
willing to spend at least something and
the way to do it in his point of view is
just to lower prices
so we want to run an av test where uh
half of our user base will see a price
point of 99 cents and half user based
will see a default price point of one
199
and he's convinced that the lower price
point is actually better
so uh we will show this a b test for two
months we will analyze the way what we
would analyze in this case we'll measure
revenue in the first 30 days for new
users only
and then we'll compare the difference
so let's
imagine that that's the data that we
received from this fake experiment
the conversion rate the percentage of
people who are willing to spend money in
the first 30 days
in a lower uh price a lower price point
group was 1.5 percent and in a high
price point the group was 1.3 percent so
it's pretty clear that uh this group
had more users who are willing to pay
however the average revenue that a
paying user is actually paying the game
is much higher in a different group so
this is make made-up data it is kind of
loosely based on the type of
distribution that you can actually see
in online gaming
and
what makes this problem really tricky is
that
a lot of your users most of users don't
pay anything then most of european users
pay very little but there are some users
who are willing to pay lots of money
they're called whales and
those few users can secure distribution
that's why the average propane user
seems so ridiculously high
i made this actually more
even more extreme than it is in reality
and
my makeup day
my fake game is a very casual game so
distribution in that game might be a
little bit different but the point is
that
you're dealing with very skewed
distributions and it could be really
really hard to analyze those
so the difference in payments
average payment for paying user is
really high if we take average revenue
of all users which means take all the
revenues in 30 days divided by all users
who were
in our game in the first 30 days
the difference is still big but we don't
know whether it's statistically
significant or not
we can calculate a p-value
uh for conversion and
it's 0.037
so it's below the alpha level of 0.05
which is this magical number that
everyone uses for no good reason really
however the practice is to use five
percent
alpha level as the threshold
and it could be judgmental you can just
decide that for our business we are
willing to take more risks
uh but
normally five percent is used you
wouldn't get fired for concluding
experiment when you say that set your
alpha level is five percent because
that's what everyone is using whether
it's right or not it's a separate
question so there's definitely more
people paying uh in our low pricing
group
and it seems to be that there are more
people that
people actually spending more in the
highest price point
um
so to analyze the difference in payments
we can try to apply a t-test
to calculate uh the difference between a
means between the averages
the formula is relatively simple and
again this test is present in in this
case in sci-fi stats a core library
and we get a value of 0.09
which at alpha level 5
we cannot actually say that it's
significant the difference seems to be
pretty big it's almost a 50
cents difference
in uh average payments however a t-test
gives us uh
the result that it's not not significant
and
another thing about t-test is that it's
not clear whether we can actually use
the test or not there are lots of uh
assumptions that goes into applying a
test
fortunately we have computers and we can
actually uh use brute force
some brute force methodologies to
calculate it so
that method is actually
pretty bad and i've seen people using
that however i would not use it so this
this is based on
you randomly split all your uh
users into five random chunks and uh you
say that
uh if uh the revit or average revenue in
all five chunks are actually above your
baseline what you're comparing then the
probability of that is happening uh
assuming that you know nothing about the
distributions
if you have five groups is less than
three three percent but it's very easy
to abuse this test and uh the point is
that don't don't use it
uh what you can do is you can just
sample from your distribution so one way
to to simulate uh
your null hypothesis is to
combine all your users into one big
chunk
uh and then um so
we
we note that the difference between your
control and test was 50 cents it seems
like a big difference so now we're just
combining all the users into one big
chunk and then shuffling them splitting
them into two different groups and
recording what is an observed difference
in average revenues
and in this case i've done that 20 000
times
and then we just calculate what is the
percentage of our outcomes resulted in a
difference uh bigger than what we
observed and in that case it's around
nine percent
again it's actually in this case it's
very close to our p-value that we got
from t-test so in that case actually we
could have used t-test however we still
did not get our significance
so um
now a vp of marketing is saying well we
definitely noted that we converted more
users and that's significant but now
you're telling me that revenues are not
significant so maybe actually we should
go with a
lower price point so we have more paying
users
there are a few tricks that we can try
to apply and generally it's this problem
is really hard and i actually haven't
found one single solution that works in
all cases but one thing that we can we
can do is that we note that uh we have
in this fake data 27 players who spend
more than thousand dollars in the first
30 days and it's not often heard of
number people some people do spend crazy
money in those online games
um so what we're doing is we're saying
let's assume that uh this price point
this
99 cents versus 199 cents
affects those extreme people as uh the
same extent as it affects those people
who spend a lot but not
in not like in this three thousand price
category
so let's just assume that those players
actually spent exactly thousand dollars
and by doing that we are effectively
making our distribution a little bit
less uh
skewed less extreme and we can apply a
simulation and a t-test and what we get
is a p-value of 0.36
so now we can actually go back and say
uh
the higher price point definitely
generated higher average revenue of user
assuming that the most extreme players
behaving the same as your mid-range or
no
high spenders so there's still users who
spend 500 and 600 dollars in the first
30 days so they're still paying a lot
but now you're making some assumptions
and again a t-test actually produced the
results that are good so in that fake
cohort i had thirty thousand users in
each group
uh and for those large numbers actually
t-tests is quite robust
uh
a few final final thoughts
what we didn't answer is uh we didn't
answer the question of how much uh what
is the difference what's an uplift that
a high price point generates or in our
case what was the down lift that the
lower price point generated
you can answer these questions by
analyzing distributions i
wouldn't go into details about how to do
that and in fact the method is
not robust enough for me to to just to
share it i'm not actually feeling very
comfortable uh sharing it for the
reasons because i still running lots of
different tests to
to conclude that it's actually robust
enough
and the second thought is that what
we've analyzed is
uh
average revenue that users spend in the
first 30 days
however what we really care about is a
long-running um
long-term lifetime value of the users
that's normally the metric that you need
to care about
and
maybe at the higher price point did
generate more revenues in the first 30
days however maybe we lost more users as
a result maybe there's a lot of users
who decided not to play our game because
competitors game games are cheaper and
therefore they went and played a cheaper
game and that's something we didn't
answer this is also a much harder
problem to solve and there is no at
least i don't know if one way to just
fix it all so uh we do calculate uh
we do project uh long-term lifetime
values and we do calculate the
difference however putting a
significance interval on top of those
calculations that are
internally based on the stochastic model
is actually really tricky
so
summary
if you know basic stats you can actually
go quite you can uh analyze a lot of uh
a b tests and so there's not a lot in a
lot of statistical tests that you
actually need to know uh t-tests are
robust enough if you have large data
however if you don't uh
have lots of data or if you're not sure
whether you can apply to tests you can
easily stimulate null hypothesis using
sampling and python is and numpy arrays
are it's easy to implement those
techniques
don't use mcmc for simple things mcmc
and bayesian statistics is really cool
if you know your priors if you uh also
actually building more complex models
and actually that problem could be
solved with bayesian methods but uh
there's also a lot of
things that you need to
to know there's a lot of assumptions
going to bayesian models and uh in that
case we didn't want to make those
assumptions
and yeah analyzing actually
highly skewed distributions is hard and
i actually
still experimenting with better
techniques to to to conclude those
experiments
thanks for attention and
questions